all right
what's up everybody how's it going happy
Saturday
hope everyone's doing well hope
everyone's ready for another exciting
stream because we're jumping in today
we're doing basically how to how to
match your 3d lighting to your 2d source
footage now if you guys look here I got
After Effects open basically you know
this here is our is our 2d source
footage and we want to put some 3d stuff
into the scene it doesn't matter what
kind of 3d stuff just some 3d stuff but
for the sake of this tutorial the most
simple explanation is using a chrome
sphere so I have this chrome sphere
right here and there's a couple
different passes that I rendered out
that make this look pretty realistic so
I just want to basically talk to you
guys how to how to take a a custom like
HDRI light map and use that to light
your scene and color correct it to match
your 2d source footage because once you
get to this point once you have a chrome
sphere in your scene and it looks like
it belongs then you can add anything
else into your scene and it's gonna look
it's gonna look perfect so this will set
you up for the most realistic lighting
the most realistic renders so yeah I'm
gonna try and keep this stream
relatively short still trying to find
the best time to stream you know we were
doing noon 10:45 the last two weeks and
it's pretty early for me it's still I do
a lot of things to kind of get the
stream going so yeah we might push to 11
I don't know what for now 10:45 is what
it will
main act so yeah how's everybody doing
thanks for joining guys thanks for
hopping in got some familiar faces in
here I hope you guys are ready to learn
learn a little bit I also got all of
your guys's weekly renders for the
weekly challenge this week's challenge
was planet and there's some really cool
stuff that you guys submitted to the
discord server so we'll be going through
the five winners after I talk about some
quick tips and tricks here on once again
how to match your 3d lighting to your 2d
source footage and I'm also gonna be
putting out a tutorial on how to make
your own custom HDR eyes I've been
talking about it for a while and it's
something that it has been a lot of fun
to work on it's just been slow because
you know I work at corridor and I'm also
doing these streams here so it's got a
lot of stuff going on but I wrote the
video last week and it's gonna be really
sweet it's only three pages long so it
should be a quick one and I just want to
walk you guys through how to get those
custom HDR eyes that I'll be using to
again match our 3d lighting to our 2d
source footage so I'm just gonna hop in
a cinema basically all I did here in
After Effects was render out a JPEG
sequence right so this is my shot I'm
not even gonna track it okay um we just
point track it later and if I hit ctrl
shift backspace or back I'm sorry ctrl
shift back slash I think it's backslash
it's the one with the question mark
maybe it's a forward slash it'll send it
to the render queue and if you go to the
bottom let's just delete the rest of
this stuff
I want to save out a JPEG sequence that
I can use as my background in cinema 4d
that's how I'm gonna reference my source
footage here so to keep things moving
quickly what I do is this is 4k footage
I'm going to go to JPEG sequence which
is I believe a custom little thing I set
up
and if you guys want to know how to do
that all you have to do is basically go
to make template right here and I save
it as underscore so all my custom ones
are at the top but it's gonna save this
out as 4k JPEG files and we don't want
that because it's just for viewing and
quick viewing in cinema 4d so I go to
best settings I take it from best or I
actually go to the resolution here it
says full I'll take that down a quarter
and if you look the size in parenthesis
actually is 960 by 540 and that is gonna
play a lot faster in cinema 4d as like a
background object so you save that out I
already did that and we'll hop in here
and let's um let's load it up so
basically we have a blank scene and
again I'm using c4d i'm using octane but
you guys can use any program that you
that you enjoy that you like the same
concept applies throughout you know all
3d software it's just a workflow thing
we're talking about so we want to let's
just put a sphere in here just just cuz
i'm gonna give it some more segments and
i'll keep it at at the bowl i also want
it sitting on the floor if i make a
plane here it's just gonna be kind of
sitting halfway through so what i'll do
is take the sphere since we know it's a
radius of 100 centimeters i'm gonna move
it up 100 centimeters and now it's
sitting on the floor ok go ahead and
give our scene a save
all right so what's next we need to load
that background so the best way to do
that in cinema is up here there's this
little floor button if I hold it down
you can create a background also if you
hit shift C you can type in background
and you can make a background that way
as well so this background popped in
here we also know we want an HDR I
environment so I'm just gonna make that
real quick and it just turned our scene
black because it's looking for a file
that's that's just black
so with background here we want to drop
that JPEG sequence on so I'm gonna make
a new octane material because we're in
octane so let's keep it uniform I'll
double click and under diffuse I'm going
to load let's see let's load that JPEG
sequence loading dock boom okay cool
you hit no and the first thing you want
to do is click the image here because we
need to make sure that cinema 4d is
recognizing it as an image sequence so
I'll click this once and if I go to
animation right here this animation tab
up top and we hit calculate you're gonna
see these frame numbers populate and the
frame numbers are nuts because in After
Effects alright if we go back to After
Effects and we hit control K this is our
composition settings then you can see
the start frame is set to four hundred
thousand three hundred eighty four you
can see it down here as well our frame
one is 400 thousand three hundred eighty
four usually I always forget to do this
but usually you're just want to hit that
set that to zero it just cleans things
up you know so now we know our render or
our scene is two hundred eight frames
long okay I don't think it's gonna
update this because we'd have to
re-render the JPEG sequence and we don't
we don't want to do that the last thing
you'll want to do is under editor you're
going to
want to check animate preview and that's
gonna allow us to scrub through and
actually see an animated preview of this
JPEG sequence in the viewport so I'll
drag and drop this on the background and
nothing happened that's because our
octane sky it actually is showing like a
visible kind of thing here a visible
representation of our HDRI environment
so we want to turn that off that's
actually what we're seeing this light
gray background though there's these two
stopwatches in cinema
the first one is viewport the second one
is in the render okay so we want to turn
off the octane sky that's on and then
off in the viewport so now we're seeing
through and we got our background here
let's hide the plane for a second and
there we go now for whatever reason it's
not working where we can scrub through
our footage we know we've done
everything we needed to do to do that if
we actually double click down here in
the material window and we made a new
material you can't see it cause my
head's covering it but if I open that up
and this is just the this is a c4d
texture this is not an octane texture
well load the image will load the same
JPEG sequence nope click the image go to
animation calculate it calculates those
frames go to viewport check anime
preview and now if we apply that texture
to the background it that should animate
that's a that's a c4d material on the
background that should work now when we
render our scene we should see something
but we're not seeing anything right now
that's because we have an octane sky
looking for an HR h dri image that is
not there so the first thing you guys
want to do when matching your your 2d
source footage and your 3d lighting
together is that there's no better way
to match the lighting than to actually
use the light
that was there that actually lit your
footage on the day and again that's
taken with a 360 camera this is a insta
361 R it has two lenses for a full 360
effect and this is how I take my HDRI
images more on that in another video I
can't wait to put put it together for
you guys it's gonna be super awesome so
that's how I'm making my custom HDRI
images any time like at corridor we're
doing Boston Dynamics whatever yesterday
we shot the world's biggest Domino run
video I'm kind of sunburned and drained
from yesterday we were running around
the city we were taking HDRI maps
because we know that we're gonna put
some 3d thing into the scene here and we
want it to react to the actual lighting
here you know that we're actually in our
scene so we would take those HDRI maps
and then later when we're compositing
the footage we're putting those dominoes
in there we're gonna put that HDRI map
in place right in this little box right
here so let's let's load this custom
hgri here but boom now if you guys don't
have the ability to take an HDR map and
actually you do that's the thing is you
do and I'm sure you guys how to do that
in that later tutorial but at the moment
right if let's say you guys don't have
the footage at the moment for whatever
reason you can't go back to set and
shoot an HDR I then honestly what I do
is I'd go to HDR I Haven and download
something that is very very close
HDR I Haven is an incredible website if
you go to HDR eyes you can search
through just a plethora of incredible HD
high maps here this is the best website
ever they're all free you can get up to
16 k resolution oh my goodness 20k
jeez okay guys like this is the best
website ever if you guys need a see our
eyes find one that is close to the to
the scene that you shot or to the
location and the lighting setup that you
actually shot and are trying to match
but again you can't go wrong with doing
them custom because at the end of the
day that's the best closest method
because you know yeah it's the same
thing
alright so we have this HDR I loaded and
what we want to do is basically get this
image on the right it's very dark we
want to get this image on the right to
have the same lighting values the
hue/saturation all that as our source
footage on the left and the best way
that I've been using to to achieve that
is by making this sphere a chrome sphere
so the first thing I'll do is I'll make
a glossy material in octane will go to
index will take that index down to one
that makes this thing a chrome ball
alright that's why you see all those VFX
artists with chrome balls it's because
they're getting actual lighting data of
the scene they're shooting it so let's
do let's just type in VFX chrome ball
and it looks like there's a bunch of
tutorials on this and you'll see people
going around with these kind of things
and like I think I think I honestly
don't know they use this and they take a
picture of this chrome ball and they
unwrap it and when they unwrap it that
is their HDRI image because when you
wrap it back around a giant spherical
kind of environment in 3d it gets you
this this effect so that's the same
thing this this matte gray ball the idea
is if you can get your cg chrome sphere
and your CG matte grey ball looking
exactly like your practical Matt gray
ball and see in practical Chrome
fear then you know you have completely
and successfully recreated the lighting
in your CG scene to match this actual
source reference these are like what are
they're called a lawn like gazing chrome
gazing spheres or something like that
gazing balls I'm not really sure they're
like weird lawn ornaments I think
they're really ugly I don't know why I'd
have this injure lawn but yeah they're
trying to sell these for a hundred
seventy bucks hundred fifty bucks
just just go to Amazon and try and find
a lawn ornament it's gonna be a lot
cheaper I promise
okay so let's drop that chrome texture
onto our sphere and in our scene it's
just so dark right it's too dark so I
think the first thing I'll do just
briefly just briefly I'm gonna go to the
octane sky I'm gonna go to the
environment tag I'll take the power up
to three let's go to ten just so we can
see a thing and then we'll we'll make
sure it's right so let's actually get
this in place um I used well actually
here real quick let's just take a look
at the HDR I um I'm just gonna open this
up a little bit for you guys to see and
if I look around you can see what's
going on here there's me on my one wheel
it's really dark
a hundred okay yeah there's me and my
one wheel taking the picture I'm using
my phone connected to the camera and
we're sitting on these like stair steps
and I'm trying to get there's the tripod
with the camera on it and I'm trying to
get I'm trying to capture this HDRI
image as close to the point where I know
they're gonna be a CG object so I'm
probably my eyeline is level with the
bottom of this railing here so if we
look at the source footage that means
that would mean that in a perfect world
the middle of this chrome sphere
is at the middle of this railing so it'd
be a pretty big one but I'm not gonna
get that intense with it I think it's
fine you can just generally have it in
place okay so yeah let's line this thing
up um I am going to go to my camera I
know I shot this on a 24 so I'm gonna
just change that setting real quick and
I'm just gonna get this roughly in place
that is basically fine right about there
now of course you'd want to line up your
camera exactly there's other tutorials
for all that stuff right and yes the
cats they're scrapping they're scrapping
in the back right now an hour and 18
minutes till SpaceX NASA launch yes yes
I think they're launching the first
astronaut in a long time which is really
crazy or it's like the u.s. is first
astronaut in a long time
these cats man they are running around
I'm have to separate these guys in a
second next time to come back I'm gonna
have to do that so alright we had this
setup right here and actually I took an
HDR I I took two I took one that was
lower and I took one that was higher
just as a test but I'm actually gonna
grab the the normal one just the loading
dock one and
all right you can see the Sun there and
what's cool about the hgri is like you
know you take this down to 0.1 and you
still retain your highlight values
you're not gonna get that from a JPEG I
promise look at this wall
you can still see the detail on the wall
we go up to one all right and now we get
the detail on the shadows you can still
see the shadows and everything so yeah I
think you guys get the idea this HDRI
map is lighting our CG scene but what we
need to do let's set let's set up a
little an alpha channel here because
we're seeing the HDRI in the background
we don't want that we want to see our
actual source footage okay
so what I'm gonna do is in octane all
right I'll go to octane settings I'll
scroll down just a little bit until you
see alpha Channel I'll check that and
would you look at that we now have our
background coming through I'm gonna
uncheck keep environment that basically
when there's motion blur there's those
there's kind of half opaque pixels when
there's intense motion blur and when you
look through those half opaque pixels
you might be seeing this background
right which isn't what we want we want
this background so I always uncheck keep
environment all right so we generally
have this in place we want it sitting on
the ground here but our but this HDRI
it's too contrasty
yeah it's definitely too contrasty so
this is the trick this is it here we
need to match the values of our HDR I
map to the values of our background
footage okay so before we do that I'm
just briefly going to put this on the
ground I'm gonna seed it on the ground
with just a plane so let's bring our
plane back in okay we can see
here that you know we're getting some
nice lighting here and actually we get
some nice bounce light from this wall
down here which is super accurate
because we're actually getting bounce
light from this pole so if I go in to
like zoom in here you can see this pole
we're actually getting some bounce light
from this wall over here right and it's
causing a nice little shadow here and of
course there's shadow from the Sun that
is blasting these rails onto the wall
right so we want to be able to replicate
that but because I took the picture in
like an overcast area I didn't take the
picture in the Sun I took in the
overcast area it's gonna assume this
whole thing is pretty overcast so we
need to bring in an extra sunlight to
beef things up we're getting ahead of
ourselves
let's let's take that plane and I'm
gonna make a shadow catcher and octane
by making a new octane diffuse material
once again you guys can always hit shift
C type in octane and you'll have all
your octane options there and then you
can make a diffuse material but typing
in diffuse and there you go so I'll go
in here and we'll go to common and I
will check the shadow catcher box right
there and I'll just drop that on to the
plane and you guys can see there's a
nice little shadow catcher going on here
so now what we want to do next is match
the values of our HDRI image to the
background here
all right so one thing you'll notice
actually when you check this plane on
the shadow catcher it actually changes
the reflection so I'm always doing the
shadow catcher pass as a render pass
because look look how it messes up our
reflections no good no good so I'll
leave that off for this image matching
here okay so what we'll do is in the
octane sky environment tag I'm just
going to scrub down here and you'll see
this icon this is our node view icon I'm
going to click that and now we have full
control over our hgri environment we can
move it around we can change colors all
that good stuff so let's add a color
correction node in between the image
texture and the environment nothing
happens because we didn't type anything
and we didn't change these numbers this
is way too contrasty but our contrast is
basically at zero so what I usually do
is I'll take the gamma and I'll go 0.5
and that gets us pretty close I think
it's a little bright I also think it's a
little saturated I'm just looking at the
ground here right this compared to this
so let's try 0.6 and I think it's
actually um yeah it's a little saturated
so maybe we'll go to point 8 on
saturation maybe point five on
saturation and now this ground kind of
matches this ground a little bit more
this is still a little dark and this is
a little bright so it's a little
contrast II still so I think what we'll
do is bring down the brightness let's
try point eight well what happens we go
point one
alright so that's obviously too much
we'll go 0.5
and the gamma will go 0.5 and you see
these highlights are pretty intense
they're clipping a little hard I'm going
to go to our octane camera tag here I'll
go to camera imager and I'm gonna crank
up this high light compression and
that's going to save our highlights you
guys can really see that taking effect
there so I'm just gonna kind of work
that in until it matches the wall okay
so this is very close
so if you can get this looking nice then
you'll be able to drop anything into
this environment and it'll automatically
be looking really nice there's a couple
things that we need to do specifically
for this shot though like maybe add a
wall here so that our shadow can cast up
against this wall right and then maybe
for the stairs we can just model the
stairs quickly and that way the ambient
occlusion from this sphere will kind of
spill off onto those stairs so we get a
really realistic look so how's everyone
doing so far thumbs up if you guys are
following along and doing a right
learning a thing or two now if there's
anything you if you guys have any
questions that pertain to what I'm doing
here just feel free to add me here in
the comments in the live feed and I
should be able to you know see what's
going on
okay so let's see I still think we can
tweak a couple things here that might
look a little bit better
yeah that feels pretty close to me you
know I'm just kind of generally looking
at these dark values to see if they
match these dark values over here I also
don't want this highlight to be brighter
than this highlight or darker than this
highlight on the wall might be a little
saturated so I'll just bring the
saturation down once more and that's
whoa what just happened
what you guys saw that what happened it
literally just disappeared where'd it go
what on earth
that was weird that was really weird I
don't know what that was about um okay
so here's another thing you know you
want to make sure H GRI is oriented
properly right so it's like how do we
know which you know which it's like I
guess the stairs were that way we'd be
looking at the stairs so we need to go
180 from there so it'd be something like
something like that I guess the best way
to find out is once you have your object
in place the best way to do this is I'll
switch this to direct lighting and that
will just pop up my HDR environment and
from there if I go back to the octane
tag here let's see the environment tag
and go to node view and I'm just gonna
give this image texture a transform and
we'll move it around so that generally
you know the door is behind the sphere
and this wall this bright wall on the
right is on the right and that's it
that's how I'm lining that stuff up back
to path tracing that'll give us back to
it get us back to our view Darkblade is
asking how are you converting your 360
images to one HDR and that's exactly
what I'll be talking about in another
tutorial
but basically what I'm doing is in
Photoshop I'm taking all of these
different bracketed exposures and I'm
combining them together in Photoshop and
saving it out as a 32-bit HDR I or HDR
image and that's allowing me to retain
my highlights and keep all the nice
exposure and lighting data so that we're
in 3d we have a lot of room to play
around okay
so let's get some let's get our shadows
going so we have our plane okay
and actually I wonder if you see the
shadows going along this line I wonder
if we can just go into node view and
like orient it so that the shadow ah
maybe maybe that works yeah that feels
about right to me so let's let's quickly
just kind of model some rough geometry
I'm gonna get a wall in here and I'm
gonna do the stairs
[Music]
separately from this plane so with the
plane I'm gonna set the width and height
segments to two just one and I'm going
to go to let's see let's uncheck check
camera
all right and we'll come in here which
briefly shape out the geometry so this
isn't going to be super the way to do
this I would probably you know track the
camera or at least get like a camera
mapping tag on this thing and like line
it up exactly but for the sake of this
tutorial
you know we we can just do this real
quick just to demonstrate so let's get
this Shadow catcher off I'm going to set
the plane to x-ray back in the camera
view and I'm just gonna start moving
some lines around and we just want this
seam for the wall that's all we want
right here we'll do the stairs in a
second I'm gonna grab this back point
and just move it so that the wall this
lines up nicely with the wall alright
and we'll grab this edge imma hit W for
move hold ctrl and drag this up so now
you have a wall there and again you see
the perspective is not right but that's
that's okay for the sake of this
tutorial so we have our wall okay and
our ground and with the shadow catcher
let's see we'll put that on the plane
and you know we'll be able to get some
nice realistic shadows in here and again
it makes our our sphere look weird and
our reflections look weird so I'll do a
render pass one where let's see
with the sphere selected I'll give it an
octane tag and under visibility I'll
uncheck camera visible and I'll render
this right maybe without the background
so we'll just render this bit as our
shadow pass or maybe our ambient
occlusion pass and then I would render
just the sphere without
the plane so it's just this right and
this would be our diffusion pass and you
can render any other passes you want
like a post-processing pass or anything
like that all right so let's just get
these stairs in here real quick so what
I'll do is I'll just make a cube right
and let's just work the scaling a little
bit
that's roughly you know some stairs I'll
go to basic and set it to x-ray in fact
I want to take the cube hold control and
just make it a plane and we'll rotate
the plane 90 degrees and I'll set the
width and height segments to zero or one
I'll hit C to make it editable and I'll
just start moving pixels around not
pixels points and edges and stuff we'll
push this back I'm holding ctrl and I'm
just shaping stairs so building out the
scene geometry helps with the shadows
all right so those stairs let's extend
these guys I want to scale them from the
left side so I'm going to use the axis
Center tool I believe is the name of
this tool yep I use it all the time and
I want to go I want to move this axis
negative X right all the way to the most
negative x point that this geometry can
handle so I'm gonna take the slider
negative x 100% and it's gonna go right
to that side I'll hit T for scale and
I'll just push this until it goes beyond
the wall and I want to rotate it
a little bit because let's get out of
our camera view see okay we're in the
stairs we want to be these are about
here I'd feel like yeah about something
like that and we'll just give the shadow
catcher to the stairs as well and you
can see here very subtly that the shadow
capture kind of clips I don't know if
you guys are seeing that right here so
we just want to make sure that these
stairs are actually lined up this corner
is actually lined up back here so for
that I'm probably just gonna take all of
these edges on let's see here
on this side and I'm gonna push them
back and you can see our geometry is
already not accurate but that's okay for
the sake of this tutorial that is fine
I just gotta show you guys briefly okay
all right um so yeah this is this is
looking pretty nice and at this point
again you can drop in anything that you
guys want
so you're seeing it's gonna look nice
I'm just gonna add a son because we do
have a son blasting you know from the
left side so let's um let's see here
let's go to our son tag let's go son
sighs just just for reference we'll set
it to 10 and we'll rotate it around it's
gonna be beyond 90 degrees it'll
probably be like 115 degrees and we'll
angle it down and we can see in our
sphere there is a highlight right there
that's our Sun if we scroll down and the
Sun tag and you click this button the
mix sky texture it's going to actually
give you both your Octane's son and your
HDRI so it's going to give you those
nice hard shadows with the Sun as well
as the nice reflections with hgri so I
want to line up this son with this son
so I'm just gonna go to the octane
Sontag and go North offset and just kind
of scrub this around until it gets to
about the point right about there and it
can come down a little bit but
cool and I'm just going to rotate it
down a little bit so it gets right in
there we'll set our Sun size back to 1
all right that was just so we can
actually see what we're doing mostly but
now our Sun is actually perfectly lined
up with our HDRI environment ok so now
what that gives us is a hard shadow
because we're definitely getting a hard
shadow right from you can see these this
railing here is getting cast onto this
wall so we're not just going to have
ambient occlusion light with our sphere
we're going to have hard sunlight as
well so you guys can see here if I bring
our shadow catcher back in it's really
casting that nice shadow onto the wall
there now obviously that doesn't look
good because we have to composite this
in After Effects and I'll briefly just
show you a quick example of what I mean
here so in in After Effects let me just
open up this file all right so if I just
bring everything back in I did this very
briefly it could certainly be better but
you can see here that the shadow it's
not going to make other shadows 2 times
dark you can see how like even if we
take our shadow down in octane it's
still making the existing shadows 2
times dark and that is such a tell such
a tell when something is CG you're
getting that double shadow effect like a
shadow overlaid on a shadow and I'd say
the best example for someone who really
just knocked this compositing job out of
the park is David Lewin Lewandowski I
think his name is you guys know him from
this video going to the store so this is
such a classic video
but if you look at his shadows there's a
moment here when he's like let's see if
I can find an example there we go okay
you see his shadow crosses over the
shadow of this pole right here and his
shadows and we cast along this wall and
it the shadow the CG shadow is not
doubling up he's actually doing an alpha
Matt a trick where you you make your
image black and white and you basically
just pull an alpha Matt right and now
the shadow isn't being overlaid it's
it's not even touching the actual shadow
so he's compositing this right this
shadow to look just like this shadow and
then when it goes over this you know
this little sign here this post
he's using a luma matte I'll show you
guys what I mean so basically in After
Effects let's just get rid of all this
stuff these are basically the layers
that are doing it okay so we have our
shadow right here and you can see what I
mean we're getting that double it's
double dark like this we don't want that
that's not real in reality this would
just block the light just as much as
this railing is blocking the light and
it would just become you know a solid
transition between shadow and light so
what we want to do is i duplicated our
footage in After Effects okay and in
there I'm basically going to take away
anything that's bright and leave
anything that is dark okay so a couple
different ways of doing this you can add
an extract effect and we're going to
take away the bright bits let's solo it
we're gonna take away the bright bits
just like that and then I'll give it a
little bit of feather all right so it's
not such a hard edge and this is a
tricky this is a tricky composite right
here to be honest with you guys very
very tricky compile
because we're we have different shadow
thicknesses and some are way softer than
the than others right like you have this
shadow here that's very very soft but
this one is more of a hard edge the hard
edge ones not so much of an issue it's
this soft little bit that is such a
difficult a difficult problem because
there's a there's some crazy fall off
but yeah if we go back here and we say
okay we want no matter what we want
these bits here to not be affected by
the spheres shadow so we'll unsolo that
and let's turn it off for a second this
is our shadow and I just turn down the
opacity to generally match you know
these values here and the easiest way to
see that is to turn on that layer right
that we just that we just used so we
have a layer on top that is just the
shadow bits with the brightest bits
taken away and it's a very hard edge so
I think what I'll do is I'll hit shift
see I'm using videocopilot BC console
and I'll just get an edge blur and
that's gonna blur that edge nicely and
then from here you can start to sorry
from here you can start to you know
there's that hard kind of dark edge you
can probably light wrap it but your goal
would be to get rid of all of this stuff
here all these lines and you know this
white kind of halo effect here but this
is definitely a difficult situation we
have found ourselves in with this
composite job so you could spend a good
amount of time doing this and trying to
get this right
but I'm not I'm not gonna do that today
because that's not the tutorial the
tutorial is to match the lighting in
your 3d scene to your 2d source footage
and yeah I feel like we we basically got
there you know you're gonna save out
your different passes as you guys can
see here and after effects I have if I
solo all this stuff I have my ambient
occlusion pass I have a diffuse pass I
have a
second diffuse pass which I've masked
away because technically you're gonna
see the shadow of this sphere on the
ground it's it looks weird if it looks
like this it's like extra bright
technically the ground would be in
shadow as well in even in the reflection
so that's why I kind of brought back in
this little bit here just to kind of
give it a little bit of something yeah a
wireframe to show that it's actually CG
yeah you know that's basically what we
did for Boston Dynamics we use custom
HDR eyes and we rendered out diffuse
pass and a shadow pass comped it
together and you know did this little
trick here where we're taking away we're
not we were making sure we're not
getting double shadows right you can see
he's masking out the shadow of the tree
here and this guy's shadow is actually
perfectly blending into that shadow
hopefully that makes sense to you guys
what a great video I think he actually
has like a very similar setup here on
the stairs
yeah these stairs are here now this is
lucky because there's no there's no hard
shadows he has to mess with it's all
just kind of ambient occlusion
so ridiculous so ridiculous good stuff
that's David Lewandowski and he's got
like going to the store too and going
sort of going to the store three it gets
crazy it gets absolutely insane alright
um yeah the shadow matching is tough
compositing is very very difficult this
was like my let's see is After Effects
crashing it might be oh wow this is my
whole computer crashing
all right we're back yeah
compositing can get really difficult you
can see here I kind of just like
feathered the edge give it a little edge
blur and just kind of worked the extract
on that but I still have these like kind
of light lines here I think an ally trap
could could definitely work and help out
that situation there but yeah that's
that's what I do to set up my CG
lightning to match my source footage and
I use that chrome ball technique to know
for a fact that it is actually lined up
and matched you know so I'm looking
through a mirror and I'm seeing my HDRI
my custom HDRI and I have my background
footage my source footage set to the
background so I can really just
composite it kind of you know kind of
composite it here in c4d octane so yeah
this is a fun little technique for you
guys I'm super excited for the HDRI
tutorial like it's gonna be good one
it's gonna be a really good one I'll
show you let's see if I have any shots
to show you guys let's see
all right yeah so this is an example of
NHGRI versus a JPEG so if you look here
and we scrub this you can see look at
the highlights you can see the
highlights are actually maintaining you
know their their their highlight nature
right
they're staying bright but if you look
at the JPEG example you can see how they
just gray out it's the difference
between this and this right you guys can
see the difference between a JPEG and an
HDR image when they're brought down the
HDRI image retains its highlights which
is what it's it's so useful in CG
because it can actually light your scene
it's super cool so yeah the tutorial is
gonna be about how to how to achieve
this
I mean how to use it in and set it up
and everything like step by step how to
set it all up so I'm just I don't want
to do a stream and then release a
tutorial because it's gonna be the same
thing but yeah that's basically it guys
if you have any any questions feel free
to ask right here
and like I said guys it's gonna be a
short stream this might be the shortest
stream I've ever done so I'm actually
going to announce the winners of the the
render challenge here right and I'll be
sure to answer any questions that you
guys have on this subject so okay yeah
let's let's check it out so the the
prompt for this week's or last week's I
guess Renner challenge was planet okay
so we got some really really nice
submissions here so I'm very very
excited to to go through these with you
guys and it's tough at a planet is tough
you know a lot of you guys submitted
planets and I feel like though you know
the whole point of this is to get some
work out
you know actually put some work out and
work on something it was tough
there were there were very few renders
that I thought like felt complete to me
a lot of them you know the lighting
wasn't right or you know just the scene
didn't feel right it was a planet sure
but it wasn't like stylized it wasn't
brought to that you know that most
complete kind of point and the five
images I chose I felt were the the five
most complete images so yeah this is
this will be exciting to go over these
with you guys
vision thank you thank you for the super
chat buddy appreciate it
do I have any any kombucha let me check
I'll be right back and we'll announce
these winners
I still got some from last week left
over this is this is bigger than my head
how about this ginger aid from GTS so
much just feel like I'm getting healthy
every time I drink it it's great so good
okay guys it's time to announce these
winners ah all right
psychic bear welcome hello hello hello
just in time for the the announcement
for these winners here of last week's
render challenge and psychic bear if you
have not entered a render challenge I
highly suggest you do this week they're
very fun and we all learn a lot from the
process so yeah oh and what is kombucha
kombucha is kind of nasty it's like
fermented tea it's carbonated and it's
good for your gut it's good for gut
health and it's about all I know okay
guys let's jump in so we have we have
these five winners let's get to it the
first winner of the planet challenge is
vanity Zeke this is amazing really
really nice render here you didn't just
make a planet you know you made a whole
scene and it's like a like a spaceship
setup and I'm actually looking at all
the detail you put into this these
monitors here for the first time earth
time 505 you're on the Mac here you got
some like book down here you got some
surface imperfections on the glass this
is really cool you know you mix mixed it
with the plants too which I really
really enjoy but yeah I think it's a
very very nice composition I really dig
it this is Center framing here on the
planet there's some things that you can
do I think to to be
up the render a little bit like
definitely setting these here I feel
like setting this this this might be
white and then glow red versus just
being red I think it's just a little
distracting maybe too because we have
this like red this bright red thing up
at the top and there isn't really red
anymore else in the scene I get I am
colorblind knees my knees are red for
sure yeah and maybe your pots are red -
I can't tell but yeah I don't know
that's a nitpick yeah this is I just dig
this I think this is really nice
congratulations Fanta Fanta T's ik I
think I'm saying her name right on
winning this week's render challenge
next up guys we have job this is super
cool I love this so much it is a really
nice POV shot through a spaceship
looking at these cargo ships here which
are incredible and I'm assuming these
ships are downloaded they look like some
what does it was his name Paul Chet
Eason Paul Chad heesun I'm gonna try and
look this guy up
he's on Instagram and he's amazing
his renders are incredible job sorry -
sorry to do this right in between but
like it just reminds me of this like
this dude's images are just incredible
his scale is nuts
he's on Instagram he's on art station
this dude is amazing but yeah this gives
me those vibes you definitely got the
chromatic aberration those chrome abs in
there um the only thing the only thing
your planet texture is a little a little
low
maybe it's 4k maybe it's 2k I don't know
there's some huge like 16 K Earth maps
out there I think NASA has some nice
ones on their site even with like
different like water maps right river
maps
and stuff for reflection catching those
reflections you can see that rivers
coming down in here so that'd be the
only thing that that's that's literally
at even nice lens flare I like it
Jobe Congrats for winning this week's
weekly challenge you guys will get the
challenge winter roll on the disc or
server so next up let's keep moving on
we have Louie Louie this is awesome I
really dig this a whole lot
it's very grainy it's very very grainy
guys always render your stuff like your
final image is rendered at a high high
samples large resolution there's no
reason not to but look at this though
you have the the lights from the dark
side of the planet wrapping around to
the light side which is always a cool
effect I think this is subtle enough I
wouldn't go any further than this I know
a lot of you guys did this which is
always super cool you got a little even
have a nice little story text down here
this is Mars
and yeah not bad on the earth texture
here I think again you could have gone a
little higher resolution with this and
you got your classic octane spaceman in
here looking nice and you even have it
looks like some Video Copilot
smudge on your lens here which i think
is great I use it a lot you got to be
very subtle with it very very subtle
with it but I think this is this is
great even adding this like this glare
on the left side of the frame adds a lot
to I think I really dig this composition
I dig your lighting and your tones here
so Congrats
Louis you are a winner for this week's
weekly challenge we got two more guys
two more winners okay so
these last two yeah they're great
um seer vanity boom this is very very
nice I really really liked your your
atmosphere around the planet you got it
right you really got it right and you
really nailed like these clouds here I
think this looks great I honestly like
is this a picture or the surrender I
don't know I really don't know this
might be a picture now that I look at it
um here's the thing though
here's the thing this this dude in the
foreground definitely needs some texture
definitely need some texture to it and
some surface imperfections could really
help your ground here maybe some
footprints or something but I really
like your composition around it reminds
me of a stews or render oh wow yeah it's
crazy I this this here I think this
might be a picture in the background huh
interesting very interesting but it does
look cool it looks very very cool I'm
down for that
so let's go on guys let's move on to the
very last winter here and this one is I
think this is my favorite out of all of
the renders from last week's weekly
challenge and it's from visual and
visual if you guys know he puts out some
really really nice renders he has won
this thing time and time again but this
is incredible your composition is so
good and your warm tones are very very
nice I really dig your render style
everything you put into your renders are
just super awesome
[Music]
I really get you know feeling looking at
this and you even have a reflection in
the window this is super cool very nice
you tell a story here too you know she's
got her helmet and everything
she's probably chilling maybe she's
leaving this planet maybe she's going
towards the planet maybe just passing by
I don't know
but it doesn't look doesn't look too hot
with this asteroid meteor shower here
but it does look cool it looks super
cool
this is desktop background were they for
sure so congrats hey congrats to all you
guys who won this week's weekly
challenge and you guys again will be
getting the role of challenge winner on
the discord server so we have to figure
out what our next challenge is Wow Wow
okay so on topic with today's lesson
with this chrome ball and matching
lighting everything I'm just gonna go
out on a whim here we're out on a limb I
think is the correct turn and let's see
I'm gonna go out on a limb and just say
that the challenge for this week is to
tell a story through a chrome ball all
right so if you guys know who I'm pretty
sure MC Escher is the artist he has a
chrome ball yeah sure yep this one here
this is a great example of you know if
one of you guys submitted this don't
submit this as your submission I'm just
saying like I wish there was a larger
larger image here but yeah you can see
he's telling a story through chrome ball
he's holding it up you can see what's
going on this is a self-portrait and his
room you can see the room and everything
his books up there and like this is an
awesome drawing now your guys's job is
to tell a story through the view of a
chrome ball okay you can do it with CG
you can draw it you know all that stuff
is all good you know just put out some
interesting art work on it you know
think of some different ideas
and this might sound difficult at first
but hey that's the whole point you know
like what if you have a job and this is
the job you have to do it you're gonna
have to do it so might as well get some
practice in now for this week when
there's no stakes you know and I want to
be I definitely want to add some more
prizes to this week's weekly challenge
or the weekly challenge in general and
I'm working on that okay talking with
some cool people about getting some cool
prizes for you guys on this so more on
that later but yeah tell a story through
a chrome ball that is the weekly
challenge for this week if you guys have
any questions on anything that we talked
about today then hit me up I'll be here
for the next five minutes just chillin
with you guys
visual I'm glad I'm glad you're down for
this you always do a great job with your
renders and I'm so super excited to see
what you do and actually you know it
kind of reminds me I I've been thinking
you know I'm always thinking I'm always
thinking what are some cool tutorials to
do for you guys and you know I kind of
just reminded me of what I've been
thinking about over the last week you
guys ever seen that video there's a few
videos there like it's like a little
mini world inside of a power outlet it's
like power outlet world or something
no not world map someone pulls back a
power outlet and revealed a cool world
inside I think you guys know what I'm
talking about power outlet
let's see small room inside of power
outlet making sure room behind an
electrical outlet yeah this are here
so I would love to do a CG version of
this for you guys I think it'd be so
much fun so I might I might try to to do
something like this next for next week's
tutorial it'd be so much fun it's just
gonna be a lot of work a lot of work
will be put into it so hopefully love
enough time but yeah that's that's
that's where my head's at right now I
don't know just kind of reminded me with
this chrome ball telling story having
put in a world inside of this other
world you know
all right Dolan is asking for some
render advice so let's give Dolan some
render advice here let's pull up your
image okay let's see here um being our
submissions and we're looking for all
right yeah okay here we go
all right let's pull this up so this is
the image here that Dakota is looking
for advice on so write out the read out
the gates if I squint and look at this
it's a little hard to tell what's going
on it kind of looks like an underwater
scene like definitely definitely
reference stuff you want to reference
something that you feel like this would
look like I'm getting vibes of like um
Titanic like deep sea Titanic search
party kind of images you know I'm also
getting some Blade Runner vibes here
like if I looked up Blade Runner ship
Blade Runner was it
20:49 was that the movie you know any
any awesome image by Roger Deakins is
gonna be sweet like this is certainly
more foggy here man that looks so cool
that looks so cool
but yeah that's not entirely the vibe
you're going for here I just say it's a
little I think it needs a bit more
clarity like what what it where are we
what's going on this looks to be like a
ship I don't know the scale of things
though I don't have a good sense of
scale also if you're in octane
definitely take your saturation to white
value two point two and that's gonna
make things bright in the center and
then it's gonna fall off to that red
glow but usually lights will be white
they will appear white when they're the
the brightest but as they fall off then
they'll have their their nice cast and
that'll be in your camera imager tab in
your octane tag okay you're gonna check
that box scroll down saturate to white
I'll just show you hit this tab here
camera imager check that box scroll down
and your saturate to white is point two
and that'll help that otherwise yeah I
think I think you could work on
composition like you have this dark line
across the left side you know and again
when I sit back and I squint it's not
the most pleasing silhouette try and go
for a really pleasing silhouette that
you feel feels really nice definitely
reference some Roger Deakins photography
like let's see always with your
reference you know that's that's the
good stuff
these images are incredible just like
look at these silhouettes you're seeing
these silhouettes here and they're
telling stories you can really see
clearly what is going on and I know
there's probably a shot in the movie
where you know there's kind of a ship
silhouette at some point but yeah
reference reference actual photography
maybe look at Titanic Titanic
let's see Titanic shipwreck so maybe you
can get kind of a nice reference
let's see ocean floor maybe I'm sure
there's some James Cameron like you know
exploratory photos or something around
that you can reference because I
definitely get that vibe with your image
as well so I think I've gone on enough
about that yeah anything else guys
before I dip out of here
probably don't have too much time to to
give advice to everyone but it just
depends on the timing and of everything
but yeah it's just important that you
guys keep submitting you know keep
creating things and keep learning and
keep growing and there should be a lot
of there's a lot of people in the
discord server that will help you guys
out as well it's a very active community
it's super cool that you guys are really
active with it yeah it's awesome it's
the best you know like every day I check
it and it's constantly full of new stuff
which is so cool it's so cool people are
actually using it and learning and
growing our assets allowed in this
week's weekly challenge yes assets are
allowed totally you can use any asset
you want you can model it you can use
the assets whatever yeah so undie Mundi
yes we do so he's asking if there's a
filmic color space in c40 and yeah I
usually just set it to linear so I'll go
up here response is set to linear and by
default is set to srgb and the gamma is
set to 1 which kind of messes up the
image makes it look all nasty and for
whatever reason it's not updating here
but yeah I'll set this response I'll go
to linear and then I'll set the gamma to
2.2 and that is basically your kind of
setup for a linear color space and all
that good stuff
how did I do the sound design for the
Domino run corridor crew video so that
would be Dean Dean Hughes and I believe
he just referenced he just pulled the
sound effects from actual Domino videos
on YouTube and overlaid them on to our
video is the quickest fastest way most
effective way to do that so will have to
be probably recording some custom sound
design for the actual Domino video which
was recorded last yesterday and will
have to probably buy some Domino's or
get some people to help us I know we
were talking with what's her name her
name's Lily have s five we were talking
with her she runs a really intense
Domino channel so we might actually
reach out to her and see if she can't
help us maybe some sound design also
maybe um with some actual runs and stuff
[Music]
am I gonna watch the SpaceX launch yeah
I might catch it later to be honest I
think I need to go out for a walk or
something so I'm actually gonna dip out
of here guys thank you for joining I
really appreciate you all and good luck
on this week's weekly challenge by
telling a story through a chrome ball
all right that's the challenge and I'll
see you guys next week
peace